Speaker 1: So yesterday we talked about a
Newsmax reporter named Emerald trying some
gotcha questions on White House Press Secretary
Jen Psaki, failing completely falling victim
to basic questions from Jen Psaki, like who
said that when she said many people are saying
so. After we did yesterday's show, there was
another press briefing. And Jen Psaki was,
I guess we might call it, confronted by Fox News
reporter Peter Doocy, who tried another one of
these lines of questioning to try to get her
and make Jen Psaki look bad. It is so sad that
this is the level of discourse that is pervading
what could be pretty informative press briefings.
But let's jump right in. And like yesterday, we
can play, you know, spot the logical fallacy. We
already covered Joe Biden's announcement that to
prevent people from turning down jobs, to choose
unemployment over the job, they are going to be
cutting unemployment benefits from people who.
Turned jobs down, this question was asked just
before Joe Biden made that statement. Take a look.
Speaker 3: And on the economy,
so unemployment only rose by
about two hundred sixty six thousand jobs in
April out of seven point four million or so
job openings. How does the White House know that
people are just choosing not to apply for jobs
because the unemployment benefits are so good?
Speaker 4: Well, first, let me say that we have
looked at the data and Secretary Yellen referred
to this on Friday or talked about this on Friday.
We don't see much evidence that the extra
unemployment insurance is a major driver in
people not rejoining the workforce. We actually
see the data and our analysis shows that
lack of vaccination, the lower rate, which is
why I refer to the data and the week that it
was taken, it has an impact. Child care has
an impact. Schools reopening has an impact.
But there is also the need to pay a livable
working wage. And that's one of the reasons
the president will talk about that this afternoon.
Speaker 1: So, Peter Doocy, is flame framing this
all as there's tons of people choosing not to
work because they make more on unemployment?
How do you know that? How do you
know that? The reality is that
every social insurance program has some free
riders. But if the program has the right balance
of benefits and safeguards and enforcement, you
don't worry about the free riders because of the
overall net benefit of the program. The problem
is Republicans have the strict father morality
where they want to make sure every individual
is receiving what they deserve. And you don't
deserve unemployment benefits if you turn down
a job. We're concerned with the macroeconomics
of it. I don't really care if there's someone
really motivated to collect unemployment and not
work as long as the system overall is providing
the economic benefit it's designed to provide.
Jen Psaki accurately points out, you know,
for most people, this is not the issue.
It's issues of child care or low wages are being
unvaccinated that are preventing people from
getting back into certain jobs. Let's continue.
Speaker 3: But as Bank of America economists who
are excited about Bloomberg story say anybody
making less than thirty two thousand dollars
a year is better off financially, just taking
the unemployment benefit. So is the White House
creating an incentive just to stay home?
Speaker 4: Well, again,
the majority of economists internally and
externally of the White House don't feel
that unemployment insurance, something that was
done at a time where to help unemployed people
get through a very difficult economic downturn
during a pandemic is a is a major driver in in our
unemployment data that there are other factors,
bigger factors that were contributing have been
contributing to the numbers we saw on Friday.
That's what we're working to address and that's
where we think our solution should be focused.
Speaker 1: So the fallacy here is cherry picking
of data. Again, we have decades of data about
social insurance programs there. I'm like a broken
record. There are always some free riders, some
people who prefer the benefits rather than doing
what's required to get off of those benefits.
Most economists understand that overall,
the enhanced unemployment has been a huge part,
arguably as big a part as the cash payments
in stimulating the economy during the
pandemic. Pieter's one example of a Bank
of America economist who spoke to Bloomberg
doesn't change the big picture understanding
of how these programs function economically.
Here's a little more of the line of questioning,
Speaker 3: the last one really quick.
The commerce secretary says the main
reason that people are staying home
is fear. How does the White House know
that people are scared? What is that based on?
Speaker 4: Well, I think what she was referring to
is the fact that there were there was a much
lower vaccination rate just a month ago and
that people are fearful about getting sick. They
are fearful about whether they're going to have
the conditions to be healthy, whether they
can send their kids to a child care center,
whether there is a child care center. So
those are all factors that are consistent with
the examples and reasons I just provided.
Speaker 1: OK, so in a sense, it's not an
unreasonable question, but understand that bigger
context. I'm the first to admit and Joe Biden
admitted it yesterday in his announcement, the
way enhanced unemployment is set up. There are
some people who could turn down a job because
the enhanced unemployment makes it more lucrative
to stay home. They're dealing with that. It's
transient. It's temporary. Enhanced unemployment
is ending. The conversation is backwards. First,
the wages, sometimes being turned down, aren't
even livable wages. Some of these wages full time,
40 hours a week don't get you the median apartment
or even a 20th, 20th quintile, 20th percentile
apartment in the cities in which the jobs are
located. That's number one. So is the problem
that unemployment benefits are too high or is the
problem the. The wages are too low. Secondly, when
someone gets what someone gets from unemployment,
enhanced or not is pennies on the dollar compared
to what huge corporations got in covid cash
from the idle program and the PP programs and
those turned into exponentially bigger slush funds
than what anyone on unemployment insurance
is getting. So, as usual, hard questions
about the wrong issue about individual social
insurance programs, essentially nothing about
the corporate welfare. And that's a typical you
know, the justice system overwhelmingly focuses
on street crime rather than white collar crime.
And questions and concerns about social insurance
programs overwhelmingly focus on the individuals
who receive very little rather than the
corporations that receive very much typical. We'll
have more on this on the show's Instagram page. So
make sure you're following us there. David Pakman
show on Instagram. Follow me at David Pakman.